der klimawandel ist da und extreme
wetterlagen erwischen uns schon jetzt
mit voller breitseite doch nicht nur das
mit der hitze kommen auch die menschen
killer nummer eins nach deutschland
subtropische und tropische insekten
einer neuen studie zufolge werden sich
moskitos wie die asiatische tigermücke
und die gelbfiebermücke in den kommenden
30 jahren flächendeckend in deutschland
ausbreiten und die ersten sind schon da
und wenn es noch heißer wird dann wird
es noch gefährlicher klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierend des seins videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasste nichts
herzlich willkommen hier in deutschland
empfinden wir mücken bislang lediglich
als lästig doch das kann sich bald
ändern denn es gibt nicht wenige mücken
die folgenreiche tropenkrankheiten
übertragen malaria dengue ca und das
west-nil-virus um nur einige beispiele
zu nennen diese sind also lange nicht
nur mehr lästig sondern sehr gefährlich
und die erderwärmung begünstigt die
ausbreitung genau solche mücken und so
finden die blutsaugenden insekten in
vielen neuen regionen dieser erde jetzt
nach und nach hervorragende
lebensbedingungen der klimawandel macht
es möglich vor allem europa aber auch
viele andere regionen der welt werden in
den nächsten jahren von den schlechteren
heimgesucht werden soll 2017 und 2018
wurden im süden von deutschland
asiatischen tigermücken aufgespürt einer
aktuellen hochrechnung eines
internationalen forschungsteams zufolge
könnten dann knapp eine halbe milliarde
menschen mehr solchen tropenkrankheiten
potenziell zum opfer fallen als bislang
dabei geht es vor allem um die
erkrankungen die die gelbfiebermücke
aedes aegypti und die tiger beides
albopictus übertragen in der aktuellen
untersuchung werden verschiedene
szenarien bezüglich der globalen
erwärmung analysiert konkret gelangen
dies durch die auswertung von daten aus
35 jahren feldforschung dazu einer der
beteiligten forscher moritz kraemer
durch die kombination von daten zur
auswertung geschichte von mückenarten zu
population zu bewegungen und
klimatischen faktoren konnten wir die
zukunft dieser krankheit zu übertragen
die moskitos vorhersagen und das
ergebnis ist alarmierend denn selbst
wenn der klimawandel noch maximal
gebremst werden kann und die pariser
ziele und die zwei grad grenze sicher
eingehalten werden steht fest sowohl
gelbfiebermücken als auch tigermücken
werden sich zukünftig in deutschland
ausbreiten dem internationalen
forschungsteam zufolge werden die
tigermücken hier schon in 30 jahren
heimisch sein und zwar im sommer ein bis
drei monate lang auf ihrem weg in
richtung norden bringen die tiere der
berechnung zufolge 150 kilometer pro
jahr vor
die gelbfiebermücken dagegen brauchen
etwas länger und werden sich wohl erst
einmal in der türkei und italien
ausbreiten ehe sie nach deutschland
kommt dort werden sie sich vor allem im
südwesten und nordosten also in
baden-württemberg und brandenburg
heimisch fühlen und das auch nur etwa
einen monat lang auch wenn das auf den
ersten blick vielleicht harmlos klingen
mag ist das eine große bedrohung für uns
denn laut der experten und expertinnen
könnten sich die tiere explosionsartig
vermehren und zu einem akuten ausbruch
von krankheiten führen und das ist ja
wie bereits angesprochen nur das
harmloseste szenario falls die
temperaturen aber in zukunft weiter
ansteigen bedeutet das für die moskitos
dass sie vor allem in europa
paradiesische bedingungen vorführen hier
werden die tiere auch die meisten ihrer
neuen opfer vor finden je nach zeitraum
und szenarien sind es bei den
gelbfiebermücken bis zu 470 millionen
potenziellen neu zu infizierten menschen
dazu kommen noch einmal bis zu 440
millionen potenzielle opfer der
tigermücken laut der aktuellen studie
könnten unter extremen klimazonen bis
zum jahr 2080 also eine milliarde
menschen mit einer durch mücken
übertragene krankheit konfrontiert
werden viele davon im westlichen europa
fest steht also tropenkrankheiten sind
schon lange nicht nur mehr das problem
ferner weltregionen andere regionen der
erde
dagegen bieten dann nicht mehr so ideale
lebensbedingungen für die moskitos in
den meisten gegenden von afrika im
amazonasbecken und südostasien würde es
nämlich zu heiß für sie werden wenn der
klimawandel weiter so voran schreitet
die infektionsraten in diesen regionen
würden langfristig wohl sinken
denn die mücken vertragen nur
temperaturen bis zu 29 grad celsius wenn
es wärmer ist gelingt die weitergabe von
krankheitserregern nicht mehr so gut
doch gesundheits experten und
expertinnen waren dass dies keinesfalls
einen grund zum aufatmen ist so zum
beispiel der us wissenschaftler colin
katzen jedes szenario und dem es zu heiß
für die weitergabe des dengue erregers
wird enthält andere und
nicht gefährliche veränderungen im
gesundheitssektor so oder so führen
höhere temperaturen also zu mehr
gefährlichen krankheiten gut ist das
also alles nicht aber wir können jetzt
konkret etwas tun wir können am 26 mai
zur europawahl gehen und zweitens genau
die partei wählen die die standpunkte
vertritt die jetzt wichtig sind und
unser überleben sichern es ist die
letzte wahl nach der die politik noch
etwas ändern kann und wir sind
diejenigen die entscheiden also lasst es
uns tun hashtag diesmal wähle ich
europawahl 2009 10
alles was man wissen muss vom minister
wissen logo anklicken und anschauen
würde ich mal sagen wir sehen uns am 26
mai im wahllokal bis dann bleibt dran